[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notre invité est philosophe alors quand
on dit philosophe on pense peut-être aux
penseurs un peu déconnecté à
l'intellectuel qui n'a pas les pieds sur
terre non notre invité et tout le
contraire il est même bien ancré dans
son époque il mène des réflexions sur
des sujets qui nous sont accessibles et
qui nous percutent la vie la mort
l'actualité plus réaliste qui réalise et
même assez positif il aime à parler
bonheur il aime parler bien-être
peut-être parce que son enfant sait son
environnement familial l'amenait tout
naturellement à la mélancolie et à
l'angoisse mais le désespoir très peu
pour lui il est loin des théories
sombres et catastrophistes à l'entendre
la clé c'est de ne pas avoir trop
d'illusions pour ne pas être trop déçu
donc avec lui le bien-être c'est quand
on a mal nulle part et puis le bonheur
c'est quand on peut se réjouir parfois
la barre il ne la met ni trop ni trop
bas s'interdit-il alors de rêver
s'interdit-il même d'espérer pour ne
jamais tomber de haut pour ne jamais
être malheureux posons lui toutes ces
question bienvenue dans un monde un
regard bienvenu André compte spamville
merci d'être avec nous au Sénat ici dans
ce dôme Tournon est-ce que je dis vrai
d'abord est-ce que pour vous la clé
c'est de ne pas avoir trop d'attente de
ne pas être trop exigeant avec la vie
pour ne pas être malheureux
non c'est pas la clé d'abord il n'y a
pas de clé mais c'est vrai que
souvent quand le premier livre que
j'avais publié un psychanalyse que je ne
connaissais pas m'avait écrit pour dire
qu'il partageait ma position justement
dans cette critique des espérances des
illusions etc parce que me disait-il en
tant que psychanalyste je constate que
l'espérance et la principale cause de
suicide on ne se tue que par déception
me disait et ça m'avait frappé parce que
ma mère elle-même qui était dépressive
qui s'est suicidé au fond quand elle est
morte je crois que tu étais après cette
lettre mais justement repensant à cette
lettre je me suis dit bah voilà au fond
voilà maman s'est tué par déception elle
s'est tuée parce que depuis des années
la vie ne correspondait pas aux espoirs
qu'elle s'en était fait je vais vous
dire la vie ne correspond jamais aux
espoirs qu'on s'en est fait s'il y a
quelque chose que la vie nous apprend
c'est bien ça sauf que l'erreur de
beaucoup de gens et notamment l'erreur
de ma pauvre mère c'est quand la vie ne
correspond pas à leurs espoirs dans
conclure que c'est la vie qui a tort
mais qu'est-ce que ça peut vouloir dire
que la vie a tort la vie même vous
arrivez à vous empêcher de l'espoir
n'est-ce pas très humain d'avoir des
attentes et de l'espoir moi j'espère moi
je suis déçu et donc j'essaye d'aimer la
vie telle qu'elle est pas vous m'avez
dit dans la présentation le désespoir
c'est pas son truc ça dépend de quoi on
parle parce que il y a en effet quelque
chose de désespérant dans la condition
humaine c'est qu'on va tous mourir c'est
aussi bête que ça et pour Latex que je
suis s'il y a rien après la mort il y a
en effet quelque chose de désespérant
dans la condition humaine qu'il faut
bien n'accepter celui qui vous dirait
j'espère ne pas mourir c'est un faux si
vous voulez sauf que une fois qu'on
accepte d'être mortel on en aime que
mieux la vie précisément vous savez
c'est une belle formule d'andrégide que
de souvent cité une pas assez constante
pensée de la mort n'a donné pas assez de
prix au plus petit instant de ta vie oui
parce que si on pensait plus souvent
qu'on va mourir et qu'après la mort il y
a rien on vivrait d'autant plus
intensément je dirais d'autant mieux que
chaque instant se détacherait sur le
fond très obscur de la mort comme dit il
a encore André Gide et donc il s'agit
d'aimer la vie telle qu'elle est plutôt
que d'en rêver perpétuellement une autre
que ça soit une vie après la mort dans
le cadre religions ou simplement une vie
rêvée j'aime mieux le réel que les rêves
vous êtes d'accord que les idéalistes
ont grandement fait avancer le monde
aussi avec leurs idéaux justement
évidemment Gandhi Martin Luther King
Nelson Mandela cette phrase si célèbre i
have a dream
va au bout de tes rêves
plutôt une formule de Martin Luther King
mais qui était l'une des formules les
plus bêtes que je connaisse parce que
c'est lutte aux jeunes gens vous
adolescents va au bout de tes rêves ça
veut dire quoi le gamin de 7 ans dont le
rêve c'est d'être footballeurs
professionnels comme en gros un petit
garçon sur deux en ce moment vous allez
lui dire quoi va au bout de tes rêves et
à 16-17 ans quand il comprend qu'il sera
jamais footballeur pro vous allez dire
quoi elle va tes rêves tire-toi la tête
ta vie est foutue vous allez lui dire
mais non la vie commence pour toi la vie
est passionnante la vie est intéressante
nous t’enferme pas dans ce rêve de
jeunesse la jeune fille qui rêve au
prince charmants et qui découvre à 17,8
ans qui a pas de prince charmant que les
hommes ne sont que ce qu'ils sont allés
dire quoi bah c'est toi bonne soeur va
au bout de tes rêves continuent à rêver
au printemps jusqu'à la fin des temps
mais non il vaut mieux aimer les hommes
tels qu'ils sont c'est à dire des vents
plutôt que de rêver du prince charmant
et pareil pour l'homme qui rêve de la
femme idéale qui n'existe pas plus que
le prince charmant et donc la vraie
question est de savoir est-ce que tu es
capable d'aimer la vie telle qu'elle est
les hommes les femmes tel qu'ils sont
une fois un journaliste demandait quel
est le genre de femme que vous préférez
je lui ai répondu les femmes qui ne te
font plus d'illusions sur les hommes et
qui les aiment quand même mais le tout
c'est qui les aime quand même et donc
voilà j'essaye de le faire j'essaie de
me faire le moins d'illusions possible
sur la vie et je ne dirais même pas que
je l'aime quand même je d'autant plus
parce que je ne m'y reproche plus de ne
pas être exactement ce que j'aurais
voulu qu'elle soit c'est intéressant que
vous ayez parlié parlé de ce petit
garçon de 7 ans qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à cette jeunesse qui veut une
planète meilleure qui a des rêves et qui
désespèrent de ne pas l'avoir va au bout
de tes rêves deux points réveille-toi
parce que la seule façon d'aller au bout
de ses rêves c'est de se réveiller et
donc face au réchauffement climatique on
peut rêver que tout va s'arranger comme
par miracle la vraie question c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait et donc il s'agit
pas de rêver il s'agit d'agir ne
confondons pas le désir qui est la seule
force motrice en l'être humain comme
disait déjà Aristote qui est l'essence
même de l'homme comme du la Spinoza avec
le rêve qui est une façon d'imaginer un
autre réel vous parliez des idéalistes
mais je suis pas sûr que Nelson Mandela
se soit défini comme idéaliste moi je en
tout cas je me sens très proche de Karl
Marx qui est un matérialiste comme moi
qui critique les rêves les illusions les
utopies pour se donner les moyens de
transformer le réel voilà et donc moi je
oui va au bout de tes rêves réveille-toi
parce que la seule façon d'aller au bout
de ses rêves c'est en sortir c'est de se
coltiner avec le réel tel qu'il est et
bien sûr d'abord pour le transformer
c'est ça votre votre apport votre
édifice votre apport à l'édifice
philosophique c'est l'instit
l'insistantialiste c'est ça que vous
avez apporté à la philosophie moderne
j'agis donc je suis
opposition avec l'existentialisme oui je
crois c'est une formule de Spinoza qui
est l'un de mes maîtres tout être tente
à persévérer dans son être on dit il
s'agit pas de se transcender il s'agit
pas d'être toujours en dehors de soi
parce que signifie le mot existence
étymologiquement il s'agit d'un système
c'est à dire d'être dans dans le réel
les pieds sur terre et d'agir pour
transformer ce réel même voilà mais
c'est pas mon apport seulement à moi
c'est tout un courant philosophique
alors qu'on peut résumer en l'appelant
le courant matérialiste il y a ceux qui
ne rêvent pas d'un autre monde qui ne
croit pas que l'essentiel relève des
idées non non l'essentiel relève du
monde tel qu'il est vous savez dans ce
fameux tableau de Raphaël l'École
d'Athènes on voit tous les cheveux Grecs
réunis
et les deux plus grands au centre Platon
Aristote Platon à la main levée vers le
ciel il désigne le monde des idées c'est
ça l'idéalise vivre dans le monde des
idées plutôt dans le monde réel et
Aristote à la main ouverte la pomme
ouverte vers le sol il dirige il montre
la terre où nous vivons où il faut
essayer d'être le plus heureux qu'on
peut voilà c'est Camus disait il n'y a
pas de bonheur de vivre sans désespoir
de vie si vous voulez aimer la vie telle
qu'elle est il faut lui pardonner d'être
mortel il faut l'aimer dans sa finitude
et bien voilà moi j'essaye de de penser
le désespoir de vivre oui il y a quelque
chose de désespérant dans la condition
humaine puisqu'on va tous mourir mais
essaye d'en sortir un bonheur de vie à
propos de peur d'angoisse d'anxiété je
voudrais vous montrer un document qui a
été délivré par nos partenaires les
Archives nationales c'est une lettre
signée par Alphonse Lavallée cofondateur
de l'École centrale dans ce courrier il
annonce la suspension des cours pourquoi
et bien à cause de l'épidémie de choléra
qui sévit on est alors en 1832 je lis un
cours passage ces peu lisible mais je le
dis pour les gens qui nous écoutent ils
parlent aussi du développement inattendu
de l'épidémie qui règne maintenant à
Paris ayant porté les inquiétudes dans
le sein d'un très grand nombre de
familles éloignées de la capitale après
avoir mûrement réfléchi dit-il j'ai
reconnu que malgré le préjudice il était
indispensable de suspendre les cours
pourquoi je vous parle de ça parce que
vous avez été particulièrement frappé
vous par la peur qui nous a tous envahi
au moment de la crise du covid cette
crise sanitaire vous avez trouvé si je
résume un peu qu'on avait collectivement
un peu dramatisé cette pandémie et dans
ce document vous voyez que les mêmes
causes engendre les mêmes effets
1832-2020 2021 on suspend la vie normale
à cause d'une pandémie que vous inspire
ce document
d'abord le fait qu'on a oublié
l'événement et je pense que dans un
siècle ou deux on se souviendra pas
beaucoup plus de la pandémie de covid
c'est ce que je souhaite je souhaite
qu'on va en sortir et effectivement
voilà pour le reste il fallait
évidemment faire quelque chose je n'ai
d'ailleurs jamais condamné le
confinement j'ai toujours dit qu'il
fallait le respecter j'ai critiqué tel
ou tel de ses dispositions de détails
mais bon c'est d'espoir ancienne va pas
revenir dessus à l'infini mais surtout
je me suis inquiété de cette peur qui en
effet
10 proportionné des gens ne parlaient
plus que de cauchemars de tragédie de
peur au ventre pour une pandémie qui est
tout à fait sérieuse qu'il fallait
affronter respecter les êtres barrières
se faire vacciner tout ça va de soi mais
enfin voilà j'ai cité la formule de
Montaigne ce dont j'ai le plus peur
c'est la peur et j'ai trouvé que cette
peur était disproportionnée et que
certaines mesures dans dans le
confinement et dans ces suites
risquaient au fond de sacrifier un peu
les jeunes les enfants les
écoliers les collégiens les lycéens les
jeunes adultes
pour préserver la santé de leurs
grands-parents et comme j'ai l'âge
largement d'être grand-parents au fond
moi j'ai ragé d'abord en tant que père
de famille
finalement on faisait tout pour
compliquer la vie de mes enfants qui
sont trois jeunes adultes pour préserver
ma santé de cette toile génère mais ça
fait 40 ans mon fils est né à 40 ans ça
fait 40 ans que je fais l'inverse tu
essayes de compliquer ma vie pour
faciliter la leur mais ma crainte
c'était qu'au fond on sacrifie l'amour
de la vie à la peur de la mort ça c'est
un contresens sur l'existence c'est la
vie qui est belle c'est la vie qui est
bonne et ça n'est pas parce qu'on va
mourir un jour qu'il faut cesser de
l'aimer je dirais même au contraire mais
la peur peut être un moteur la peur
déclenche de l'adrénaline la peur
déclenche de l'action des inventions on
a inventé un vaccin qui peut-être
servira pour d'autres maladies vous
voyez la peur est-elle si négative
et tous ceux qui avaient le plus peur la
peur n'a jamais rien inventé c'était
avant les gens les plus intelligents et
les plus compétents et qui désiraient
aider la vie à se préserver mais il
s'agit pas de condamner le désir
simplement dans les différentes formes
du désir la peur est sans doute la plus
la plus détestable la peur c'est le
contraire du bonheur finalement on n'est
jamais aussi malheureux que quand on est
mort de trouille et c'est pour ça qu'on
est plein d'espoir parce qu'en vérité
comme la dyspinosa il n'y a pas d'espoir
sans crainte ni de crainte sans espoir
vous demander est-ce que vous
l'appliquez à vous-même mais bien sûr
pas toujours si un de mes enfants est
gravement malade et je parle
d'expérience j'espère seulement
évidemment qu'il va qu'il va guérir
puisqu'on vit dans la peur on vit
forcément dans l'espoir simplement la
vraie question c'est pas d'espérer ou
pas qu'il guérisse c'est de tout faire
pour qu'il guérisse et de tout faire
pour éviter qu'il tombe malade et donc
là encore agir agir vouloir désirer
aimer plutôt que s'enfermer
perpétuellement dans la peur vous savez
comme disait Victor Hugo qui était bien
placé malheureusement pour le savoir il
a perdu sa fille Léopoldine faire des
enfants c'est donner des otages au
destin
j'en ai fait aussi la cruelle expérience
mais justement on va pas s'enfermer dans
la peur parce qu'on a fait des enfants
et peut-être pour nos enfants le poids
d'angoisse ils partent en mobylette et
il y a l'angoisse de papa et de maman
sur le porte-bagage et c'est
insupportable et donc acceptons que oui
nos enfants sont mortels comme nous
faisons tout pour mourir avant eux enfin
pour qu'il meurent après nous c'est
plutôt ça le problème voilà et donc
aimant la vie mais pour aimer la vie il
faut accepter qu'elle soit mortelle on
va revenir sur votre parcours vous en
avez déjà un petit peu parlé mais on va
approfondir cette vie ce parcours que
vous avez eu d'abord votre enfance vous
en parlez très librement on pense plutôt
malheureuse dans une famille déchirée
avec un père très méprisant avez-vous
dit un jour une mère aimante mais
dépressive vous l'avez dit vous dites
que votre père avait une qualité c'est
qu'il était facile à haïr vous avez
passé votre enfance à souhaiter qu'il
meurt parce qu'il rendait votre mère
malheureuse avez-vous dit est-ce que
c'est ce départ difficile on peut le
dire qui vous a amené à la philos qui
vous a amené à philosopher est-ce que
cette philosophe la philosophie a été
indispensable et comme une thérapie oui
en partie plus compliqué que que ça mon
père était facile à lire en effet mais
ça pour un fils c'est une chance pouvoir
s'opposer clairement franchement à son
père c'est tout à fait structurant par
contre ma mère est un peu difficile à
aimer je l'aimais je l'aime toujours
passionnément elle est morte évidemment
mais je l'aime toujours mais elle était
difficile à aimer parce qu'au fond alors
toute dépressive qu'elle fut elle avait
des moments de gaieté de joie comme
n'importe qui sauf que ces moments de
joie ça sonne est faux on avait le
sentiment que c'était une forme de
théâtre destrionisme comme
diadogénopsychiatre c'était du cinéma du
chiqué pourquoi elle le faisait pour
vous pour faire illusion c'est le
sentiment qu'elle donnait et alors
qu'avèrement quand elle était triste
quand elle pleurait dans mes bras
c'était d'une vérité totale et donc j'en
avais dans ma petite tête d'enfant ou de
jeunes adolescent tirer l'idée que la
vérité était du côté du de la c'est à
l'inverse la joie était du côté de
l'illusion et là j'étais très mal parti
dans l'existence et puis 17 18 ans je
découvre la philosophie notamment les
penseurs grecs mais aussi bien Spinoza
d'autres qui me disent exactement le
contraire c'est l'illusion qui rend
malheureux c'est la vérité qui libère
qui rend libre comme disent des
évangiles qui permet d'être joyeux
d'aimer la vie telle qu'elle est
autrement dit la philosophie m'a
enseigné le contraire de ce que je
comprenais avec ma mère de dire que la
philosophie a été ma bonne mère n'ont
pas que ma mère était une mauvaise mère
il était très aimante mais elle était
malheureuse elle était dépressive et
elle vivait effectivement dans une
espèce de cinéma permanente
distillionnisme permanent dont il a
fallu que je sorte voilà et c'est pour
ça que la philosophie m'a aidé à aimer
la vie telle qu'elle est et non pas
telle que ma mère la réveille à force de
la rêver qu'on s'attend qu'elle n'était
pas comme ça effectivement ma mère en
est morte elle s'est suicidé une enfance
marquée aussi par un problème
d'élocution c'est ce que je lisais quand
on voit l'orateur que vous êtes
aujourd'hui on se demande comment vous
avez fait vous avez transformé ce
handicap en force qu'en est-il ressorti
comme maintenant c'est ce qu'on ferait
c'est ce que j'ai fait pour l'un de mes
fils d'ailleurs non non mon père se
moquait cruellement de moi
ce qu'elle pourrait faire de d'abord de
me faire souffrir beaucoup
mais peut-être fait aussi de me motiver
à contrôler ma parole et donc peut-être
si je parle mieux peut-être qu'un autre
c'est que pour moi la parole a été un
effort un acte de la volonté précisément
c'est pas je me laissais pas parler
comme ça spontanément quand je parlais
spontanément les gens ne me comprenaient
pas et donc il a fallu que j'apprenne à
parler tard vers 7 ans 8 ans 12 ans en
revanche aussi alors peut-être sur ce
père qui se revanche peut-être voilà et
puis après il y a eu la politique ça 68
arrive là-dessus il a bien fallu prendre
la parole en assemblée générale la
politique m'a passionnée et puis après
lui renseignement donc ensuite venu au
fond une espèce de professionnel de de
la parole dont je me méfie un petit peu
je sais que l'une des statues là c'est
l'éloquence on en parlera tout à l'heure
pensant à vous j'ai relu le chapitre
éloquence de mon dictionnaire
philosophique je dis que c'est à la fois
un art l'art de l'éloque de l'éloquence
et un talent on est plus ou moins et le
camp pour conclu en disant art mineur
talent dangereux et je pense qu'en effet
l'éloquence est à la fois un arm mineur
et un talent dangereux qui m'arrive d'en
faire preuve je n'en plains pas je ne
culpabilise pas mais d'évidence
l'essentiel est ailleurs certains
politiques usent de l'éloquence à
l'excès pas beaucoup
dans l'ensemble ils sont bien médias
comme orateur il faut bien le dire alors
tout le monde célèbre Mélenchon comme
oratoire parce qu'il sort un peu du lot
c'est vrai qu'il a un talent que je ne
conteste pas mais enfin qui ne paraît
pas non plus exceptionnelle non non mais
en plus tu avais la télévision ne pousse
pas à l'éloquence parce que l'éloquence
c'est l'art du discours et quand on fait
un discours à la télévision ça sonne là
encore théâtrale factice et donc ce qui
est difficile pour nos politiques c'est
qu'il faut qu'ils inventent une espèce
d'éloquence très particulière qu'on
pourrait appeler l'éloquence télévisuels
parce que Mélenchon est très bon comme
tribain à la tribune il est moins bon à
la télévision et je lui reproche pas
parce que c'est un art extrêmement
difficile et d'ailleurs moi j'ai horreur
de ça pour tout vous dire au Parlement
on peut être éloquent
mais c'est vrai quand on voit des
discours de nos parlementaires dans
l'ensemble on adhère pas l'éloquence
mais bon c'est pas grave c'est pas ça le
plus important mais vous êtes allé sur
le terrain de la politique et ça
m'intéresse parce que votre parcours
politique est atypique lui aussi vous
avez été AD pendant 10 ans au PCF Parti
communiste français vous avez été initié
au marxisme en Cagne prépa littéraire 50
ans plus tard vous l'avez dit vous-même
vous avez voté pour Emmanuel Macron en
2017 comment on passe de Marx à Macron
d'abord
bien avant la Cagne c'est 68 moi qui m'a
plongé dans la politique comme des
centaines d'entre nous je suis devenu
d'ultra gauche vers le 13 mai au matin
13 mai 68 au matin avec ce que ça
comporte de dérisoire de niaiseries de
suivi mais aussi de sincérité
d'enthousiasme de passion et tout ça bon
et puis on avait comme
c'était avec dans un groupe d'amis on a
assez vite compris que du côté du
gauchisme il n'y avait pas d'avenir
fallait venir à une politique
raisonnable il a semblé que le Parti
communiste pouvait servir de vecteurs et
donc on a fait ce que nous appelions
entre nous de l'entrisme intelligente et
entrer dans le parti communiste n'ont
pas pour préparer une session à la façon
trop que moi plus tard mais pour essayer
de le transformer de l'intérieur et ça
échoué j'ai compris que ça échoué enfin
nous avons compris encore je parle le
seul que c'est chouette quand le Parti
communiste 1 a rompu l'union de la
gauche pour laquelle on se battait de
depuis des années et deux à approuvé
l'intervention soviétique en Afghanistan
moi j'avais adoré au PC parce qu'il
avait condamné l'intervention soviétique
en Tchécoslovaquie je l'ai quitté 10 ans
plus tard parce qu'il approuvait
l'intervention soviétique en Afghanistan
voilà donc cette volonté de transformer
le Parti communiste en partie
démocrate révolutionnaire mais démocrate
anti staliniens font ça échouer et puis
des constat a été sec et bien moi comme
la plupart de mes amis nous sommes
devenus tranquillement sociaux-démocrate
c'est-à-dire de gauche espérant une
transformation de la société
que par la voix de d'une réforme alors
Macron c'est différent parce que je ne
sais pas si lui se définirait comme
social-démocrate de gauche il l'a dit en
tout cas elle le disait au début de
quand il préparait dans la campagne
électorale le problème de Macron me
semble-t-il ça a été autre chose au fond
on a dit parfois ni droite ni gauche je
sais pas ce qu'il dit il a raison de ne
pas le dire parce que ça veut dire rien
ou alors le centre dire pas grand chose
non non ceux qui disait c'est étroite et
gauche et droite et gauche ça veut dire
quelque chose on connaît bien l'Union
nationale or j'avais le sentiment et je
viens dire toujours en partie le
sentiment que face au terrible problème
auquel nous sommes confrontés le
problème écologique la transition
énergétique etc une nationale pourrait
être utile et peut-être même la seule
voie
efficace c'est-à-dire laisser un peu de
les divergences idéologiques se mettent
d'accord sur sur quelques priorités
absolument il se trouve que le Parti
socialiste n'en a pas voulu ce que j'ai
regretté si le PS avait soutenu Macron
après son élection tout a été différent
on aurait peut-être eu un gouvernement
de centre gauche plutôt que de centre
droit et puis surtout ce qu'on a
découvert entre-temps d'abord c'est que
Macron a échoué dans sa volonté de
réconcilier les Français il avait raison
dans le diagnostic et puis au bout de
quelques années des gilets jaunes donc
au tout début de son mandat on découvre
qu'il est quasiment encore plus détesté
que l'été Sarkozy ou François Hollande
donc est-ce que l'échec est de sa faute
sans doute pas totalement mais c'est
moralement c'est l'intention qui compte
mais politiquement c'est le résultat et
donc il y a un échec politique de Macron
que moi-même et évoqué dans la presse
qui est qui est incontestable et qui
vous empêcher de voter pour lui en 2022
non non j'ai encore voté pour lui mais
avec un peu moins
enthousiasme mais parce que le reste me
paraissait pire et le sentiment que
Mélenchon nous permet dans une gauche
radicale dont on fait d'avance que ça ne
marche pas c'est-à-dire tu étais pour
refaire l'erreur de 81 et aboutir deux
ans après en 83 à un constat de faillite
et changer complètement de politique
est-ce qu'on va recommencer est-ce que
la gauche va recommencer un
définitivement ce genre de choses non
mais surtout pourquoi parce qu'elles
vendrait du rêve elle manquerait de
réalisme
tu te fais plaisir avec des mots c'est
la gauche en France n'a jamais réussi
jamais à gouverner plus de 5 ans de
suite la droite sera fréquemment que
l'année et 10 ans 15 ans de suite la
gauche jamais dans d'autres pays des
pays scandinaves en Angleterre il arrive
que la gauche gouverne pendant 10 ans 15
ans en France jamais pourquoi parce que
parce que me semble-t-il la gauche dans
l'opposition tient un discours tellement
radical tellement
utopique du côté du rêve de l'illusion
que elle se casse la gueule au pouvoir
mais je voulais revenir sur Macron il y
a aussi autre chose
5% de gauche radicale la nuque 25% ou
30% chez les électeurs d'extrême droite
et puis 25% de autour de Macron donc
tout ça tout ça est malsain et donc ça
veut dire qu'il faut laisser une chance
à l'alternance il faut pas s'installer
dans le centre je souhaite que Macron
réussisse si c'est encore possible mais
la vraie question c'est comment est-ce
qu'on sort d'un pouvoir centriste ou
central sans tomber dans l'un des
extraits mais donc il faut préparer la
prochaine alternance pour qu'elle ne
nous amène pas au triomphe d'un
extrémisme André kospourvil vous avez vu
l'émission vous l'avez dit vous-même
tout à l'heure donc vous connaissez
aussi la séquence photo j'ai des photos
à vous montrer
la première la voici c'est le philosophe
un autre philosophe Michel Onfray avec
lequel vous avez déjà débattu tous les
deux je lisais vous êtes inspirés par
les écoles épicuriennes et matérialistes
lui aussi est assez présent dans les
médias comme vous d'autres points
communs avec lui
oui enfin je sais pas c'est
difficile à dire j'ai de l'estime pour
Michel Onfray critiqué
j'avais écrit dans un de mes livres la
phrase est également celle-ci on
Maturette sur mon rapport au
christianisme je disais c'est l'une de
mes différences avec mon ami Michel
Onfray c'est pas parce que je suis athée
que je vais cracher sur 25 siècles sur
2000 ans de christianisme
25e de judéo christianisme
a pris ça pour une insulte alors je lui
dis non quand je dis que tu craches
quand je détente que tu craches sur le
christianisme c'est pas moi qui te
crasse dessus alors j'ai repris le
dictionnaire je lui ai dit mais cracher
sur ça veut dire manifester de la
rancoeur du mépris de la hargne contre
quelque chose je lui dis mais écoute le
moins qu'on peut dire c'est que ta
manifesté ça vis-à-vis du christianisme
tu en as parfaitement le droit mais je
trouve que moi qui suis athée j'ai pas
de haine j'ai pas de rancœur j'ai même
pas de contre le christianisme il a
considéré que c'était une insulte donc
il considère qu'on est brouillé que j'ai
rejoint ces adversaires
il m'arrive bien plus souvent de le
défendre auprès de mes collègues le plus
souvent le déteste que de le critiquer
voilà donc je constate avec tristesse
qu'il s'est brouillé avec moi mais je
n'ai pas envie d'en dire du mal parce
que je n'aime pas dire du mal de mes
amis quand bien même ce sont d'anciens
amis et peut-être que vous réconcilierez
à l'issue de cette émission et des
propos que vous venez de tenir sur lui
une autre photo c'est Anne Bert c'est
une écrivaine je le dis pour le public
qui nous écoute c'est une écrivaine qui
a choisi sa mort qui a choisi
l'euthanasie en Belgique en 2017 elle
souffrait de la maladie de Charcot et
j'en parle parce que vous êtes membre du
comité d'honneur de l'ADMD c'est
l'Association pour le droit de mourir
dans la dignité et vous êtes vous-même
favorable à la dépénalisation de
l'euthanasie vous trouvez qu'on meurt
mal en France qu'on ne meurt pas dans la
dignité en France
c'est toujours dit que cet appellation
association pour le droit de mourir dans
la dignité était une très mauvaise
appellation c'est pas une question de
dignité le mourant qui souffre
atrocement a exactement la même dignité
que vous et moi c'est une question de
liberté c'est une question de souffrance
et donc il faut donner aux gens la
possibilité de mourir sans souffrir et
de mourir librement si c'est parce
qu'ils sont atteints d'une maladie
incurable ça c'est pas de pousser au
suicide évidemment des gens en bonne
santé mais voilà moi ce que je souhaite
c'est que si je suis atteint de la
maladie de Charcot par exemple je puisse
mettre fin à mes jours librement
autrement dit je plaide pour le suicide
assisté et donc pour la dépénalisation
de l'euthanasie alors les gens me disent
parfois mais tu as qu'à si tu veux te
suicider t'as pas besoin de l'aide d'un
médecin
par la fenêtre du cinquième étage c'est
quand même une mort très désagréable on
n'est même pas sûr de se réussir
d'autres
on choisit de penser en voiture contre
un arbre que c'est c'est quand même des
morts qui relèvent d'une forme de
barbarie mais surtout c'est pas ça la
question se posera pour vous comme pour
moi non pas quand nous serons chez nous
quand nous serons à l'hôpital ou dans un
EHPAD et bien essayez de vous suicider
dans un hôpital ou dans un EHPAD vous
m'en direz des nouvelles et donc ça veut
dire qu'on peut rentrer dans un EHPAD
pour un an deux ans cinq ans parfois 10
ans pourquoi pas avec l'envie de mourir
et la totale incapacité de l'obtenir
alors que les plus riches prennent un
billet de train pour aller en Suisse en
Belgique ou on a le droit de mourir nos
pas dans la dignité c'est pas la
question que tu vois mais de mourir
librement voilà et donc je suis partisan
de la dépénalisation de de l'euthanasie
parce que j'aime passionnément la
liberté et parce que j'aime aussi
passionnément la vie mais justement je
souhaite qu'elle puisse rester à peu
près agréable jusqu'au bout et si on
peut éviter six mois d'agonie atroce à
quelqu'un qui le demande pourquoi di de
lui refuser vous la connaissez déjà ma
dernière question que vous en avez déjà
parlé mais je vais quand même vous la
poser en est entouré de quatre statues
qui représentent chacune une vertu on
est entouré de la sagesse de la prudence
de la justice et de l'éloquence laquelle
vous caractérise alors celle qui
n'importe le plus individuellement c'est
la sagesse bien sûr mais enfin nous
sommes dans un lieu politique je demande
pas aux élus au sénateurs par exemple
d'être sage à ma place et donc pour ce
qui est de la politique la justice et la
prudence compte davantage la justice qui
indique la fin le but comme disait mon
ami Luc Ferry avec vous et la prudence
la phonécise la sagesse pratique qui
permet de choisir les moyens efficaces
enfin la suite vient de dire bon il faut
combattre le chômage mais comment à la
justice ne répond pas c'est la prudence
la sagesse pratique va nous permettre de
trouver les moyens efficaces pour faire
reculer le chômage et donc en matière de
politique tout le monde peut être
d'accord sur la fin de personne et
contre la justice
le débat l'enjeu c'est dans le choix des
moyens efficaces bien complète merci
infiniment de récompense pas envie
d'avoir été notre invité dans un monde
un regard merci on se retrouve très vite
sur Public Sénat à bientôt
[Musique]